This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Since the early 1500s, when Sir Thomas Moore coined the word utopia, and probably well before then, people have been thinking about how to design their ideal society. Maybe it's one that doesn't use money, or one that drops the traditional family structure in favor of raising children collectively. One, two, check. That's producer Delaney Hall getting ready to visit a sort of utopia. And before she left, she packed her bag, tested her recording equipment, grabbed a few extra packs of AA batteries, and I'm just gonna fill up the left this tub of water.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。自16世纪初托马斯·莫尔爵士创造了“乌托邦”这个词以来，甚至可能在此之前很久，人们就一直在思考如何设计理想的社会。也许是一个不用钱的社会，或者是一个放弃传统家庭结构、转而集体抚养孩子的社会。一、二，检查完毕。那是制片人德兰妮·霍尔，她正准备去访问一种乌托邦。在她离开之前，她收拾了行李，测试了录音设备，多拿了几包AA电池，我只是要把这个水盆的左边装满水。
And then thoroughly washed every item of clothing that she was bringing with her. I have a box of baking soda just dumping some of it in this tub of water. To be more specific, I soaked my clothes in a tub of baking soda for 48 hours and showered with Dr. Bronner's unscented soap for two weeks before I left. I've got an all pair of jeans, I'm putting them into you. Delaney reports for the show, state of the reunion. Every episode is about a different place,
然后把她带去的每一件衣服都彻底洗了一遍。我有一盒小苏打，正把一些倒进这个水盆里。更准确地说，在我离开之前，我在小苏打水里泡了48小时的衣服，并且用布朗博士的无香肥皂洗了两周的澡。我有一条旧牛仔裤，我正把它放进水里。德兰妮为《重聚之州》节目进行报道。每一集都讲述一个不同的地方，
so she travels a lot. But she doesn't usually go to these kinds of extremes to get ready. But this is an unusual reporting trip I'm about to go on. I'm headed to an isolated community in Eastern Arizona on the outskirts of a small town called Snowflake. And the people who live there have given me very special instructions
所以她经常旅行。但她通常不会为了做准备而采取这种极端的做法。不过，这是一次不同寻常的报道之旅，我即将出发。我要前往亚利桑那州东部的一个偏远社区，在一个叫斯诺弗莱克的小镇郊区。住在那里的人给了我非常特殊的指示，
for how to get ready. Because for some people in Snowflake, utopia just means not being physically sick. A community of people who live just outside this small rural town have a medical condition called MCS, multiple chemical sensitivity. It means there is seriously intolerant to laundry detergent, perfume, cigarette smoke, car exhaust, commercial cleaning products. And snowflake is a community designed around keeping that sort of stuff out. People who have MCS can be seriously affected,
教我如何做准备。因为对斯诺弗莱克的一些人来说，乌托邦意味着不会生病。生活在这个偏远小镇外围的一个社区的人们患有一种名为MCS的疾病，即多重化学敏感症。这意味着他们严重无法耐受洗衣粉、香水、香烟烟雾、汽车尾气、商业清洁产品。而斯诺弗莱克就是一个旨在把这些东西挡在门外的社区。患有MCS的人会受到严重影响，
sometimes disabled, by migraines, muscle pain, rashes, nausea, and fatigue. But most scientific studies have not shown a strong connection between chemical exposures and symptoms. There's no real medical consensus about what causes the illness, and doctors disagree about whether symptoms
有时甚至因偏头痛、肌肉痛、皮疹、恶心和疲劳而丧失行动能力。但大多数科学研究并未表明化学物质接触与症状之间存在强烈联系。对于究竟是什么原因导致这种疾病，目前并没有真正的医学共识，医生们对这些症状到底是
are physiological, psychological, or both. That means that people with MCS are often dismissed as, well, hypokondriacs. Many find themselves without sympathetic medical care or access to services that people with recognized disabilities might have. There are a subset of doctors who believe in MCS and treat it, but most mainstream physicians avoid the diagnosis. And so a lot of people with the illness fall back on trial and error, designing their diets, habits, and environments to try and make themselves feel better.
生理上的、心理上的还是两者皆有，意见不一。这意味着患有MCS的人经常被当作疑病症患者打发。许多人发现自己无法获得富有同情心的医疗护理，也无法获得残疾人可能享有的服务。有一部分医生相信并治疗MCS，但大多数主流医生都在避开这种诊断。因此，许多患者只能依靠反复试验，设计自己的饮食、习惯和环境，试图让自己感觉好一些。
It's my first morning in snowflake. And this is really an incredible landscape. Very flat, very dry. You can see a long way in every direction and the sky is very blue. The houses out here are all built in a really simple style. They look like they have sheet metal walls, Sheat metal walls, it's truths. They're generally pretty small. Delaney didn't go to snowflake to find out whether or not MCS was quote unquote real. She went to learn how people have built new lives
这是我在斯诺弗莱克的第一个早晨。这里的风景确实令人难以置信。非常平坦，非常干燥。无论朝哪个方向都能看得很远，天空非常湛蓝。这里的房子都是用非常简单的风格建造的。它们看起来像是用金属板做墙壁的，金属板做墙壁，还有……它们通常相当小。德兰妮去斯诺弗莱克不是为了弄清楚MCS是不是所谓的“真实的”。她是去了解人们是如何在那片偏远的草地上建立新生活的，
and homes designed to fit their very particular needs, out there on the remote grassy plateau. Hi, I hope you're Delaney. Hi, man. plateau. Susan Maloy has short curly hair and a wide grin. It's below freezing, but all the windows in her small house are open. For people with MCS, their home is the only environment they can really control. I'm suddenly very aware of my smell. I'm worried I didn't prepare well enough. Susan offers me a cup of coffee.
并建造出满足他们特殊需求的房屋。嗨，我希望你是德兰妮。嗨，曼。高原。苏珊·马洛伊留着短卷发，笑容满面。气温在冰点以下，但她小房子里的所有窗户都开着。对于MCS患者来说，他们的家是他们唯一真正能控制的环境。我突然对自己的气味非常敏感。我担心自己没有准备好。苏珊请我喝杯咖啡。
Do you like milk in it? Sure. And then, just like I worried. I smell cigarettes. What would you like me to do? I'm not quite sure. OK. I'm going to get close to you for just a sec, OK?
你喜欢在里面加奶吗？当然。然后，就像我担心的一样。我闻到了香烟味。你希望我怎么做？我不太确定。好吧。我要靠近你一会儿，好吗？
Sure. It's a blouse, maybe. OK. Do you mind if I give you something else to wear? No, not at all. OK. Like, you have guest clothes. OK.
当然。可能是衬衫。好吧。你介意我给你换身衣服吗？不，一点也不。好吧。比如，你有访客穿的衣服。好吧。
Delaney is not a smoker, but this is the level of Susan's sensitivity. Susan is at the heart of this community. People have described her to me as a fairy godmother and the queen. She works with curious outsiders like me. She also attends conferences on disability rights and spends hours each week answering phone calls from people who are sick. She's healthier than lots of her neighbors, but that hasn't always been the case. For me it was just real fast. I felt this just bizarre feeling in my head and my sinuses and the palate of my mouth and my throat also all closed. Susan was living in San Francisco when she first got sick back in the early 90s. Her sensitivity
德兰妮不是吸烟者，但这正是苏珊敏感的程度。苏珊是这个社区的核心人物。人们向我描述她为仙女教母和女王。她接待像我这样好奇的外来者。她还参加残疾人权利会议，每周花几个小时接听生病人们的求助电话。她的健康状况比许多邻居都要好，但情况并非一直如此。对我来说一切都发生得太快了。我感到头部、鼻窦、口腔上颚和喉咙都有一种奇异的感觉，全都合上了。苏珊在90年代年初刚生病时住在旧金山。她的敏感度
began to cascade which is pretty typical for the illness. Her allergy to chemicals grew into a sensitivity to food and clothing, then electricity. Telephones, computers, kitchen appliances, pretty much everything became toxic to her. Francher had to go. The rugs had to go. I had two girlfriends come over and take my clothes. Just got rid of almost everything right away. Susan slept on friends' porches in her car and at her parents. At her sickest, she couldn't even drink
开始级联反应，这对于这种疾病来说非常典型。她对化学物质的过敏发展成对食物和衣物的敏感，然后是电力。电话、电脑、厨房电器，几乎所有东西对她来说都成了毒药。地毯必须扔掉。地毯必须扔掉。我有两个女朋友过来拿走了我的衣服。几乎立刻把所有东西都扔掉了。苏珊睡在朋友的门廊上、她的车里以及父母家里。在她病情最重的时候，她甚至不能喝
chemically treated tap water, and her mom put buckets in the yard to gather rain. Then a friend with MCS invited her to visit Snowflake, a rural high altitude community with good, clean air. He'd discovered it a few years before, driving around the country, trying to find a place where his symptoms wouldn't be so severe. And when Susan visited, for me, the improvement was so radical. You know, you get out of the car, you feel better.
经过化学处理的自来水，她的妈妈在院子里放了水桶来收集雨水。后来，一个患有MCS的朋友邀请她去斯诺弗莱克参观，这是一个海拔高、空气清新良好的乡村社区。几年前，他在驾车全国各地寻找一个症状不会那么严重的避难所时发现了这个地方。当苏珊去参观时，对我来说，这种改善太彻底了。你知道，你一出车，就感觉好多了。
You can walk, you don't need the oxygen tank. Your speech is clear. I didn't exactly want to move here, but my body said, yeah, we're moving here. For Susan, the move felt like a passage, like a journey between two different worlds. Like in the old days for someone to get on a ship and go to the United States from Ireland, they didn't really want to leave, but just they weren't able to make it anymore. And so they took this huge risk and got on a ship. I think it felt a little bit like that to me.
你可以走路，不需要氧气瓶。你的说话很清晰。我并不是特别想搬到这里来，但我的身体说，是的，我们要搬到这里。对苏珊来说，这次搬迁感觉像是一次过渡，就像两个不同世界之间的旅程。就像过去有人从爱尔兰坐船去美国一样，他们并不是真的想离开，只是他们再也无法维持下去了。于是他们冒着巨大的风险登上了船。我想这对我来说有点那种感觉。
Gradually more people moved to Snowflake. They came from all over, an engineer from Denmark, a marketing director from Toronto, a chef from the Philippines, a teacher from San Francisco. Now there are about three dozen households scattered across this area, all united by this illness. And they're not the first people in history to move because of sickness. For ever, there have been people who have had to relocate because of particular medical problems or health reasons.
渐渐地，越来越多的人搬到了斯诺弗莱克。他们来自各行各业，有来自丹麦的工程师、来自多伦多的营销总监、来自菲律宾的厨师、来自旧金山的教师。现在大约有三十多户人家散落在这个地区，他们都因这种疾病而团结在一起。他们并不是历史上第一批因为生病而搬迁的人。一直以来，都有人因为特定的医疗问题或健康原因而不得不重新安置。
In fact, the history of medical migration to this part of the country goes back a long ways. A hundred years ago, doctors encouraged people with tuberculosis to head west for the same clean, dry air that brought Susan here. So many patients ended up in Arizona that tent cities sprouted up across the state and locals gave them a nickname, Lungers, because of the hacking cough that characterized the illness. So this is not an uncommon experience for human beings. It's just right now it's our turn, or yet, or the new guys. But the complicated thing about this illness is that it's so unknown.
事实上，向这个国家这个地区进行医疗移民的历史可以追溯到很久以前。一百年前，医生们鼓励肺结核患者向西前往，正是为了寻找让苏珊来到这里的清新、干燥的空气。如此多的病人在亚利桑那州落脚，以至于帐篷城在全州各地涌现，当地人给他们起了一个绰号叫“肺结核患者”，因为这种疾病特征性的咳嗽声。所以这对人类来说并不是一种罕见的经历。只是现在轮到我们了，或者说，我们是新来的人。但这种疾病复杂的地方在于它是如此未知。
Some doctors would argue that this place isolates people, pushes them deeper into their sickness. All to talk about diets and remedies and building techniques only reinforces what might be better treated in other ways. But Susan told me this place saved her life. The kitchen's the same as the bedroom, which is the same as the living room. I mean, I basically live in one big room. Susan built this house herself with help from friends.
一些医生会认为这个地方孤立了人们，让他们更深地陷入疾病之中。所有关于饮食、疗法和建筑技术的讨论只会强化那些可能用其他方式治疗得更好的东西。但苏珊告诉我，这个地方救了她的命。厨房和卧室是一样的，客厅也一样。我的意思是，我基本上住在一个大房间里。苏珊在朋友的帮助下自己建造了这栋房子。
The people here in Snowflake might be the closest thing there is to a MCS think tank, and they've developed building techniques that help manage their sensitivities. That means using quote-unquote safe materials, like ceramic tile or concrete floors instead of carpeting, which traps chemical odors. Susan also used foil-lined sheet rock, which covers her walls, giving the whole inside of her house a silver sheen. I just couldn't afford to risk paint. You know, if you get the wrong kind of paint, your whole house is unlivable, maybe forever or maybe, at least for several months or a couple years.
斯诺弗莱克的人们可能是最接近MCS智囊团的存在，他们开发了有助于控制敏感性的建筑技术。这意味着使用所谓的“安全”材料，例如瓷砖或混凝土底板，而不是会藏匿化学气味的铺地毯。苏珊还使用了内衬铝箔的石膏板来覆盖墙壁，使她整个房子的内部都带有一种银色的光泽。我实在承担不起使用油漆的风险。你知道，如果你用了错误类型的油漆，你的整个房子就会变得无法居住，也许是永远，或者至少是几个月甚至几年。
But maybe the most striking thing about this house is the way that Susan has isolated most of her electronics in a separate room, which she can completely shut off from the rest of the house. That's because many people with MCS also experience sensitivity to electricity. You designed it pretty strategically with that room in mind, but the room at the front of the house is the one where electricity comes into one corner of the house. It all comes in right over there. And the rest of the house doesn't have to be as affected by it. She keeps her television and a VCR in a separate room,
但也许这栋房子最引人注目的是，苏珊将她的大部分电子产品隔离在一个单独的房间里，她可以把这个房间与房子的其他部分完全隔离开来。这是因为许多MCS患者也对电很敏感。你在设计时非常有策略地考虑到了那个房间，但房子正面的那个房间是电力进入房子一个角落的地方。所有的电都是从那边进来的。而房子的其余部分不必受其太大影响。她把电视和VCR放在一个独立的房间里，
and she's constructed a thick window to watch TV through while keeping the equipment isolated. The television is an ancient one, I mean, by today's standards, and it's really nothing special other than it's old. I don't want to have new chemical emissions in my house, you know, from plastics and so forth. If there's any way around it. And so this one is old and aired out. And this glass sheet in front of it is to keep the fumes in that room and I can open the front door and let the fumes go out without contaminating the inside of my house.
并且她建造了一扇厚厚的窗户，以便在保持设备隔离的同时透过它看电视。按今天的标准来看，这台电视是一台老古董了，除了它很旧之外，真的没什么特别的。我不想在家里产生新的化学排放物，你知道的，来自塑料等等。如果能避免的话。所以这台是旧的，并且已经散过味了。前面这块玻璃板是为了把烟雾留在那个房间里，我可以打开前门让烟雾散出去，而不会污染我屋子内部。
The house is modest but you can tell how much it means to Susan. She shows me every corner and every adaptation. It's her safe haven. And there are lots of people who are desperate to move out here to live in a little place just like this. When Susan's phone rings, it's usually not a good sign. I don't get calls from people for whom everything is going great. You know? Hello? Hi, Susan. This is young Robinson. How are you?
这房子很简陋，但你能看出它对苏珊有多重要。她向我展示了每一个角落和每一处改造。这是她的避风港。有很多人迫切希望搬到这里来，住在像这样的小地方。当苏珊的电话响起时，通常不是什么好兆头。我接到的电话都不是一切都很好的那种。你知道吗？喂？嗨，苏珊。我是扬·罗宾逊。你好吗？
Hi. Do you know how proud place is available because I could not be doing work. And I've got to get out of here. My skin is literally burning and bleeding from the pollution. Susan gets a few calls like this a week from runners. People who are moving from place to place trying to find somewhere that feels safe. Snowflake isn't the only community of its kind, but it's one of the largest and most established. Still, that doesn't mean there's ruin for everyone. I'm sorry, but there is some living there. Susan tracks the limited housing in Snowflake, and she breaks the bad news when she can't help out.
嗨。你知道有什么空房地方吗，因为我没法工作了。我必须离开这里。污染让我的皮肤简直在燃烧和流血。苏珊每周都会接到几个这样的逃亡者打来的电话。这些人从一个地方搬到另一个地方，试图找到一个感觉安全的地方。斯诺弗莱克并不是唯一一个这样的社区，但它是最大、最成熟的社区之一。不过，这并不意味着每个人都有地方住。我很抱歉，但那里确实有人在住。苏珊记录了斯诺弗莱克有限的住房情况，当她无能为力时，她会带来坏消息。
I don't know. You never know. I'm waiting for a miracle to happen. I need a miracle. I don't have any miracles. I wish I did. I did go. I know you're not asking me to get off. I need to go. I'm emotional that's what a typical call is like, you know, people who are real sick where they are and need to be in it. Another kind of housing and there isn't any. Over the years enough people with MCS have come to Snowflake that the wider community has adapted to them, at least a little bit.
我不知道。你永远不知道。我在等待奇迹发生。我需要一个奇迹。我没有奇迹。我希望我有。我走了。我知道你不是在叫我挂断。我得走了。我很情绪化，典型的电话就是这样的，你知道的，那些病情真的很重、需要换个地方住、却又无处可去的人。多年来，足够多的MCS患者来到斯诺弗莱克，以至于更广泛的社区已经适应了他们，至少有一点适应。
There's a real estate agent who helps people find MCS-friendly properties. There's an organic food store, which is kind of unusual for a rural town of 5,000. The owner there will sometimes shop for people with MCS and leave the groceries outside for them to pick up so they don't have to come into the store, which smells like incense. And then there's the dentist. And my EI patients usually come in through the back door, they wait in their cars, and we have a separate entrance right here. EI is short for environmental illness, another term for multiple chemical sensitivity.
这里有一位房地产经纪人，专门帮人们寻找适合MCS的房产。这里有一家有机食品店，对于一个5000人的乡村小镇来说这很不寻常。那里的店主有时会帮MCS患者采购，把杂货放在外面让他们自己去拿，这样他们就不必进店了，因为店里闻起来有香火味。然后是牙医。我的EI患者通常从后门进来，他们在车里等候，我们这里有一个单独的入口。EI是环境性疾病的简称，是多重化学敏感症的另一个术语。
Melissa is a hygienist here at Sierra Dental. Sierra Dental regularly sees about 40 patients with MCS and they've adapted their practice to make it friendly to people with sensitivities. And I usually tend to see them at 8 o'clock in the morning because that's I haven't wiped my room down with chemicals because I did it the night before. So I don't have to worry about them smelling the cab aside wipes, which is what we use in the dentist. Melissa also shuts down the X-ray machine, opens the windows, and turns off the fluorescent lights if patients request it. As far as polishing teeth, I use plain pumice stone. So that way they aren't getting the chemicals.
梅丽莎是塞拉牙科的一名牙科卫生员。塞拉牙科常规接待大约40名MCS患者，他们调整了诊疗方式，使其对敏感人群友好。我通常倾向于在早上8点接待他们，因为那时候我还没有用化学品擦拭房间，我是前一天晚上擦的。所以我不用担心他们闻到卡巴斯代湿巾的味道，我们在牙医诊所里就是用这种湿巾。梅丽莎还会关闭X光机、打开窗户，如果患者要求的话，还会关掉荧光灯。至于抛光牙齿，我用的是普通的浮石。这样他们就不会接触到化学物质了。
The other thing we do here in the office is, we don't use fabric softener. I actually use a natural laundry soap we use, a lot of us do. No sprays, no smelly lotions, things like that. So, you know, like I understand it, a lot of them, they're really sick because of chemicals and electronics and all sorts of things.
我们在办公室里做的另一件事是，我们不使用衣物柔顺剂。实际上我们很多人都在使用天然洗衣皂。不用喷雾剂，不用有香味的乳液之类的事物。所以，正如我所理解的，他们中的许多人因为化学物质、电子产品和各种各样的事物而病得很重。
So, lots of people are skeptical when they first hear about the illness, but Melissa just kind of rolled with it. She did research, she believed her patients' complaints, she even sympathized a little bit. I remember as a kid, I spent in a Vermont, we went to the Yankee-Doodle candle factory. And it was my only experience with a migraine headache. It was smelling all of those, the smells. And I don't have chemical sensitivities, but being around all of those smells all day long was the worst headache of my life. So I equate that with all the time with these poor people.
所以，很多人在第一次听到这种疾病时都持怀疑态度，但梅丽莎只是顺其自然。她做了研究，相信患者的抱怨，甚至有点同情。我记得小时候，在佛蒙特州，我们去过洋基蜡烛厂。那是我唯一一次经历偏头痛。闻到所有那些气味。我虽然没有化学敏感症，但整天待在所有这些气味周围是我一生中最严重的头痛。所以我总是把这种感受与这些可怜的人联系起来。
We're back on Susan's porch and she's looking out over the landscape. She knows that this community depends on the tolerance and accommodation of people like Melissa. All it takes is one family building a gas station out there on the road and a lot of us that have to move. In a little while, Susan has a date with another friend in the community. She's going to read him a book, which means she'll stand outside his house, hold the book up to his window, and turn the pages. He's too sensitive to let her, or even the book itself, inside. It makes life here in Snowflake seem so precarious.
我们回到了苏珊的门廊上，她正眺望着远处的风景。她知道这个社区依赖于像梅丽莎这样的人的宽容和包容。只需要有一家人在路边建一个加油站，我们当中很多人就不得不搬家。过一会儿，苏珊要和社区里的另一个朋友约会。她要给他读一本书，这意味着她会站在他家外面，把书举到他的窗户前，然后翻页。他对她甚至对书本身都太敏感了，不能让她进屋。这让斯诺弗莱克的生活显得如此岌岌可危。
It is fragile. side. It makes life here in snowflake seem so precarious. It is fragile and I know it and I treasure it for being here at all. So I am hyper-vigilant about always hoping that nothing's going to happen to us. You know, always hoping that we're going to keep getting away with the slife that we've built here. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Delaney Hall from the public radio show State of the Reunion. If you like great stories about places and the communities that people create, and I'm guessing you do, so true is the show for you. Find out more at stateofthereunion.com. Our show is produced by Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery, Truffleman, and me Roman Mars.
这是脆弱的。外面。这让斯诺弗莱克的生活显得如此岌岌可危。它是脆弱的，我知道这一点，我珍视它能在这里存在。所以我高度警惕，总是希望我们不会发生任何事情。你知道，总是希望我们能继续在 我们这里建立的生活中幸存下来。“99%隐形”本周由公共广播节目《重聚之州》的德兰妮·霍尔制作。如果你喜欢关于地方以及人们创造的社区的精彩故事，我猜你一定喜欢，这个节目正是为你准备的。请在stateofthereunion.com了解更多信息。我们的节目由山姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·明格尔、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。
We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produce the offices of Rxign in beautiful downtown chemical free oakland california if you like the stories in this show you can get more and more and more of it on facebook twitter and tumblr but 99 p i h q is at 99pion.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的奥克兰市中心无化学污染的 Rxign 办公室制作。如果你喜欢这个节目中的故事，你可以在 Facebook、Twitter 和 Tumblr 上获得更多精彩内容，不过 99 p i h q 的网址是 99pion.org。来自 PRX 的 Radio Tapio。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。